What if our efforts
to build a better planet
benefited half of this room more?
What if we reduced our emissions
but increased the gap
between men and women?
What if by 2050 we reach net zero,
but women had a lower chance
than men to find a decent job?
Disturbing, right?
And yet, this is exactly
what my colleagues and I found
while studying the links
between women and climate
over the last years.
Our research has shown
that climate action,
as it is unfolding,
could set gender equality
back by 15 years.
I'm going to say that again.
So climate action, not climate change,
climate action,
meaning all the efforts
that are being made
to reduce our emissions,
to adapt our lives to a warmer planet,
could actually set gender equality
back by 15 years.
I know what you must be thinking.
This is a total buzzkill.
(Laughter)
So the climate challenge
is not big enough,
you’re adding solving gender
equality to the equation?
I get the feeling.
But the good news is, if we do it right,
we have a unique chance to advance
both the climate agenda
and gender equality.
How?
By being intentional about it.
But first, let's go back to that 15-year
setback risk I mentioned.
I give it to you, it's counterintuitive
to say that climate action
that aims at building
a more viable future to all of us
could actually have a negative impact
on gender equality.
So let me explain.
Obviously women, as well as men,
women even more than men,
will benefit from living
in a more sustainable planet.
Their health, their education,
their livelihoods will improve.
But what I'm saying
is that there is also a risk
that women might miss out
on the green economy's massive investments
and job opportunities.
And here are two examples of that.
By 2030,
65 million green jobs will be created.
The highest-paid, more stable ones
will require what’s called STEM education:
science, technology,
engineering and mathematics.
Today, women represent 35 percent
of STEM students globally.
So they might be less qualified
to access these green jobs.
Second example:
by 2030, companies
in highly emitting sectors --
such as energy, building materials,
industrial goods --
will be spending as much
as 500 billion dollars
to train their employees
in new green skills.
Now, these industries
are historically male-dominated,
so mechanically, women are less likely
to participate in these retrainings,
widening the skill gap
between men and women
again in accessing the jobs of the future.
So, see, the risk is real.
Women might miss out
on these opportunities and investments,
or at least miss out on part of them,
even if this wasn't the initial intent.
So what is it that we need to do
to have a climate action
that solves these two
major challenges at the same time:
gender equality and sustainability?
Well, we need to do something
that seems very simple,
yet very often overlooked.
When investing in green projects
and developing green products,
crafting green legislations,
we need to make sure that women
as well as men will equally benefit.
Not more, not less.
Just equally.
Might seem obvious.
You might even think,
"Isn't that what we're already doing?"
But history has showed us
that time and time again,
even though this is
what we think we're doing,
this is not what is actually happening,
at least not naturally, organically,
not without an explicit intent.
So we need to take this intent
into climate action.
We need to naturally, systematically,
intentionally embed
what you could call a gender lens
in all of the green economy’s
investments, projects and legislations.
And I am not just talking
about projects targeting women
or funds dedicated to women
or a gender day in climate negotiations.
I am talking about gender
as an intentional forethought
in every green project,
every green investment,
every green legislation.
Let's take an example.
Green cities.
Green cities are a great illustration
of how we could integrate this gender lens
and have climate action
boost gender equality
instead of setting it back.
From Chicago to Shanghai,
from Copenhagen to Rio,
most large cities have ambitious
programs to become greener.
Two trillion dollars
will have to be spent every year
for the next 20 years
to upgrade urban infrastructure
and make it more sustainable.
And this covers housing, energy
safety, public transportation,
green spaces, you name it.
With the right approach,
these cities can become greener
and more inclusive of women.
Now greener, they sort of know
how to do that.
They have already initiated
multiple projects,
and there is already a lot
of research in that field.
But becoming more inclusive of women,
we hear less about that.
This is less documented.
And yet there is a great story
that can serve as an inspiration.
This story takes place
in the beautiful city of Vienna,
in Austria.
In the '90s,
planning officials in Vienna realized
that women were less satisfied
with transportation systems
than men.
Because these systems are designed
for people going between home and work,
between suburbs and city centers
at mostly set times.
But women,
although they make up the majority
of public transportation users,
women's trips are nothing like that.
They are much more fragmented,
they are much shorter,
they require multiple
transportation modes,
and they don't necessarily happen
during rush hour.
All of this because women
combine their work trips
with their domestic
and caregiving responsibilities.
And this, transportation, is a major
factor when it comes to women’s labor
and participation [in] the economy.
They also noticed something else.
Before the age of nine,
boys and girls would equally go to parks.
But when girls reach the age of nine,
something strange happens.
They almost disappeared from public parks.
So they did some research
and they confirmed that, no,
it’s not that all of a sudden,
when girls turn nine,
they no longer are interested
in public parks.
It's again, because of the way
these parks are designed
with their single large open space
and multiple football cages,
boys feel welcomed,
girls feel they need to compete for space.
So they just stopped going there.
So bottom line, through these
two examples and many more,
they realized that the gender-neutral
approach that the city had
and that most cities in the world have,
this gender-neutral approach
can actually be a women-blind one.
So they decided to intentionally design
a gender-equal urban planning program.
So they surveyed men and women
to better understand the way
they live in the city.
They brought in female architects
and urban planners
to participate alongside
their male colleagues,
to participate [in] the city’s redesign.
They added gender assessment
in social housing
and infrastructure contracts.
So see, just like that,
every step was made
with the intention,
the explicit intention,
to make sure that women
will benefit as well as men.
Again, not more, not less, as well as men.
So in parks they have added foot paths
to divide up space.
They have integrated
a wider range of activities
such as volleyball.
And just like that,
teenage girls came back to parks.
And this has benefited teenage girls,
but not only them.
Every year since 2009,
except for COVID years,
Vienna has been named
the best city in the world to live in.
Now, it's not just the gendered approach,
but it clearly contributed
because for the first time,
the specific needs of the other
half of the population
were taken into account.
Now, what does Vienna's story tell us?
It tells us that if we want women
to benefit from a green city project,
from an urbanism project,
or from any project,
it needs intention.
And intention means
at least these three ingredients:
upfront and ascending
women specific needs,
even if the project is not specifically
targeting women;
involving women in the design
of the project;
and specifically measuring
the impact of the project on women
to be able to adjust if necessary.
So this way, with this approach,
we could correct the biases
that are behind the gender-neutral
urban planning programs
that exist everywhere.
And we could duplicate Vienna’s
intentional experience
in every green city.
And I left the best part for the end.
When involved in urban planning,
women proved to be active agents
of sustainability.
Statistically, the most sustainable cities
are also the ones with the highest
representation of women
in policy making and leadership positions.
So this gendered approach will not only
make green cities more inclusive of women,
it will also make them greener.
Treating women exactly like men,
as I have heard multiple times
from policymakers and leaders,
is not what will get us to gender equality
because it turns a blind eye
to the biases that we all have,
and it tends to perpetuate
pre-existing inequalities
and could even be widening them.
Urbanism is just one example
of how the green economy
will revolutionize the way we move,
work, eat.
If we intentionally embed a gender lens
in the way we will sustainably rebuild,
rethink all of these aspects,
we can advance gender equality
at the same time,
and this will in turn have
a positive impact on the planet.
See, we can save the world
all at once, after all.
Thank you.
(Applause)